el ecuador se mantiene con una tensa
calma e incertidumbre por saber quién
será el contendor de andrés cerrados
ante la segunda vuelta electoral el cr
amanecer rodeado de vallas metálicas y
un fuerte operativo de vigilancia
militar y policial luego el llamado a
movilizaciones hacia quito guayaquil y
cuenca para exigir apertura de actas r
conteo de votos y otros reparos del
movimiento político pachakutik ante el
organismo comicial con un poco más del
99 por ciento de las actas escrutadas y
según los resultados emitidos guillermo
lasso pasaría a la segunda vuelta sobre
el candidato pérez que hasta el momento
los separa más de 17.000 votos de
diferencia pero el movimiento indígena
reclama actas con menos votos obstáculo
en sus veedores e intentos de hackeo su
sistema de control electoral el
movimiento indígena denuncia fraude
electoral deberá comprobar en las
próximas horas mientras que se
movilizarán hacia el consejo nacional
electoral hacia la contraloría y la
fiscalía donde pedirán la nulidad de las
elecciones en algunas provincias y
destitución de los consejeros
electorales un proceso con muchas quejas
ante el ente rector del que hoy se
espera un informe de escrutinios en su
pleno a cuatro días de las elecciones
generales